التطورات الملف النووي الايراني حيث قال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
ان تصريحات رئيس الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافاء غير جديره به لانه شخص مسؤول
وتسائل نتنياهو قائلا لماذا اعتبر جروسيا
ان اي هجوم عسكريه على المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه امر محظور مؤكدا ان نهج
الدبلوماسيه مع طهران على وشك الموت
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه رفاهيل روسي
اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم الاسرائيليه على
المنشات النوويه خارج عن القانون خارج عن
اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص المسؤول مثل جروسي
هل يجوز لايران التي تدعو بصراحه ووضوح
الى تدميرنا وان تحضر الادوات لقتلنا من
الواضح انه مسموح لنا بالدفاع عن انفسنا
جاءت في اعقاب تصريحات اخرى من طهران تشير
الى تفاقم الازمه مع الغرب بشان برنامجها
النووي فالخلافات الايرانيه الغربيه لم
تحسمها زياره جروس الاخيره الى طهران رغم
تصريحاته التي بدت متفائله فبعد ساعات
قليله من زياره جروسي خرجت منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه لتنفيه التوصل الى اي
اتفاق على تركيب كاميرات جديده في المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه
اجهزه المراقبه هذه كان قد تم وضعها بموجب
الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015
لكنها ازيلت العام الماضي كنتيجه الانهيار
الاتفاق في اعقاب انسحاب واشنطن منه عام
2018 في عهد الرئيس ترامب وقال المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الايرانيه بهروس كمالوندي
انه لم يحدث اي نقاش او اتفاق مع وفد
مفتشي الوكاله الدوليه لتركيب هذه
الكاميرا
التصريحات الايرانيه تتعارض مع ما اكده
جروس بعد عودته من طهران مباشره والتي قال
فيها انه توصل الى اختراق يتعلق بموافقه
ايران على اعاده تشغيل كاميرات مراقبه في
عده مواقع نوويه وزياده وتيره عمليات
التفتيش
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قالت ان
ايران قدمت تطمينات بانها ستتعاون اخيرا
في تحقيق متعثر بالفعل بشان جزيئيات
اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في مواقع غير
معلنه فضلا عن اعاده تركيب اجهزه المراقبه
التي ازيلت وقد اصدرت الوكاله وايران
بيانا مشتركا لدى عوده جروس من زيارته قبل
يومين فقط من اجتماع ربع سنوي لمجلس
محافظي الوكاله المؤلف من 35 دوله وقال
دبلوماسيون ان البيان خاض في القليل من
التفاصيل لكن احتمال حدوث تحسن ملحوظ في
العلاقات بين الجانبين من المرجح ان يحول
دون مسعا غربي لقرار اخر يطلب من ايران
التعاون
ومع ذلك زياره جروس يبدو انها لم تحدث اي
اختراق مهم فايران قدمت وعودا مماثله من
قبل لكنها لن تتمخض عن اي شيء يذكر
التعهدات التي اكدها جروسي وسارع الطهران
لنفها تاتي بعد تقارير اشارت الى انها
رفعت نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم الى مستويات
تقترب من 90% وهو ما قد يمكنها من صناعه
القنبله الذريه